sua jovem aqui serra eu acho que buscar
o chifre do bole-bole está preparado e
olha o pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um nome e um estranho um grave
problema o chip do blog estou a ficar
muito grande então eu tenho que ter uma
solução para isso e eu estava a pensar
em encerrar os títulos do bode
então é isso que vai acontecer hoje
portanto fez um vídeo até o fim porque
vai acontecer muita coisa e isso vocês
são novos e que não quer a usar jeans
que remo e deixei muito líquido vídeo é
porque isso ajuda muito no youtube não é
dá pra criar os meus filhos portanto é
fácil isso vocês já conhecem órgão
xeique do bosque carioca saiu agora um
cheque 2.0 então é muito melhor do que o
1 0
lembro que nos fundos é muito grande o
quadril é basicamente um cheque de
responder a uma aplicação com esta
aplicação vocês podem ganhar telemóveis
consolas mensalidade grátis
muita coisa querendo muito embora mas se
você como é que funciona explica lá é
melhor como é que ganhou o oscar deixe
lá camorra acha aí pra nós conseguirmos
ganhar bastante e vem aí mais um
telefone abril o sheik e o que tem que
fazer é só depositar assim o cheque e
quando você digita o telemóvel vocês vão
ler cartas cartas vezes vão dar essa
premissa é uma coisa nova e xei 2.0 é
que elas podem trocar essas cartas com
os nosso time é imaginem vocês têm que
pagar 2 você me ter cartão que vocês têm
caído discutir em voz e também tem a
carta não foi obtida a néon olha acho
que pode ficar casa
assim algumas letras agora olha tu vens
cá eo próprio quarta 2 pela quarta
novela então bora bora e sim tem mais
chances de ganhar prêmio é por vai bem
porque neste arranque dos concertos
também tem mais prémios bem cartas de
monstros muita coisa houve uma coisa
muito boa e vocês podem convidar os
nossos amigos para oscar usando voskhod
inclusive vou deixar aqui o meu que dar
que ordem por telefone lá mas as pessoas
para que vocês intimidam aqui onde
cheguei aqui eu vou deixar o meu código
net que são também passei lá adicionem e
embora o problema
e por que não tem acompanhado os últimos
vídeos pessoal nós temos um novo aumento
é que na colômbia um [ __ ] oficialmente
chama-se [ __ ] é o nosso novo cobrir se
vocês não conhecia o banco vai perceber
que o espírito é um deles porque a
história toda portanto passar por lá
então tentaram de causando bola e rolar
e aparentemente os tons escolhidos na
época o bope já deve ter o sentido do
que vai acontecer eu já sabia buscar o
chipre dela e eu não quero ir nela
porque os o chip como arma contra mim
sempre
no documento ele sempre que o futebol é
mais praticar o chip do nosso pobre e
precisa então de uma certa é essa que eu
não tenho em casa dá um para lá comprar
os carros só o senhor mandou comprar o
outro e uma certa proprietários copa do
mundo será que sair porque os fóruns e
alguns treinos mas a chamada olha nós
nos problemas se o psdb já escolheu
morrer uma pronta vai votar sim é fácil
o que faz e como vocês podem ver já
temos aqui é serra praticar os tipos de
bola e eu só não encontrou bola e tudo
bem
a vale também tem muita certeza o [ __ ]
linda até deu m
aí está com medo ainda [ __ ] ela está o
nosso blog sua autoria que serra é hoje
que buscará o chifre do bole-bole está
preparado estava a brincar vocês acham
que eu sou maluco suficiente para cortar
o chip do blog em casa isso não se faz
oque uma pedrinha e te falo que vou
fazer hoje existe realmente esse
problema o bolo e elejam muito com o
chifre de ontem achar uma solução em uma
legenda antes que surja que casa que eu
passo a vida a marcar agora porque eu
quero brincadeira então essa é a forma
que eu mostre que quer brincar uma
acabou por arranjar muito eu já vou
largar isso porque ainda vai jogar
contra o câncer em um show de um passo
muito fofo 50 dinho a boca de lobo funes
terceiro gol pouco tempo fazer este
caminho todos pensam meu deus parece uma
senhora idosa para lá então continuar um
vídeo pessoal e toque urbano e fugir
como se o vale uma missa vespertina que
tudo e vai ter um corpo é a mim nem
gerando comida e fome vai aparecendo por
exemplo é positivo quando giba eu já
coloquei que bicicleta pra eu não
conseguiram e eu só eu posso já fugiu
também se o papa incluindo não fuja fica
aqui tudo bem vai voltar àquele que isso
promovendo toma conta da nossa senhora
de fátima com deus
não acho que eu acho que vai pro meu ver
como estava a dizer antes do bambu e
fugir para lá continuar aqui street o
que eu vou fazer agora é uma armação
para os tipos de bob com este porte com
bolha e enquanto isso o senhor vai
também tomar conta aqui do passarinho
mas sempre tento não parceira
eu acho que vou ter que tomar conta de
manter a parceira mãe não faz ideia mas
espero que eu fique bem acho que vai
encontrar mas sim eu espero que esse
fundamento e não possuir em belém assim
pensa que é o primeiro dos nossos pais
no shopping e shopping ser contínuo e
sim que as compras clemente boa podemos
lá sempre toda hora era de propósito era
minha mãe não gosta do filme que tem aí
é que já não quero quero
a bola fazendo xixi fora vamos possa eu
acho que é melhor não ficar aí olha lá
então só vamos começar então a construir
o nosso reforço para o chifre do blog e
só vamos usar o plástico bolha vamos
tentar fazer um mall e colocar o solo se
perdeu é só isso é básico disse eu acho
que vai ajudar porque sei que é feito
para escoar encomendas para não caírem
nos partir então eu acho que era certo
ela começa e já agora é muito embaixo
que você já só acho que o chifres em
greve ou não sangra o que vocês acham
porque se eu jogasse mesmo tipo de jogo
que acontecerá se um tipo une ou é uma
coisa que tem vai expor dentro e sangra
muito embaixo você show ela e agora
estou fazendo o nosso escudo do plástico
bolha bororó é muito bom a comentar
estas coisas foram lá então só vamos
construir um novo para o chip do bode e
eu tenho que utilizar porque eu vou usar
um x-ato não votar outra coisa qualquer
coisa que segundo chico do garimpão
buscar um pouquinho só tem uma coisa a
menina é um evento que vou sair daqui
com o modo do chipre demorem a lei é só
entrar assim exposta mesmo né
só agora sim acho que está a discutir
promover mais bola mais leve a mal mas
acho que agora faço assim eu sou um
cachorro que choveu esse já não dói não
é uma empresa muito mas não vai fazer
isso bem
[Música]
o massacre souza um negócio para não
cortar da mesa e já cortei mesa três
games agora precisa clínicas mãe nunca
estragar nossa mesmo olha que a fita
cola o senhor não definiu qualquer
produção você e você um ko o leque de
fita cola produção você está a falhar o
que resta por fazer esta festa é pra
pintar paredes eu não quero falar sobre
isso no crime também não cresce
escrevo na caixa o senhor quer uma vida
kolarov
isto é normal sentir sintomas que tinha
com o irmão opção isto neste domingo
aqui essa também não é excelência esta
época para o oceano
eu espero que funcione eu nem vou
portanto é preciso entrar lá e assim
nunca vi não pode vai conseguir atingir
as linhas belas pernas
essa armadura um dos símbolos do vale
não seja o próximo para lá uma fita cola
o vídeo escondendo ouvidas caneta cola
preta sendo assim ninguém é muitos anos
viram frango ruan que o turista que
estava então a senhora já foi na volta a
jogar mas agora acho óptimo podem não
ver os meninos tinham anunciado que a
caixa de produção acho que mostra como
funciona o candidato josé da sua missão
encontrar o goring o voo estarei com
minha fé e vamos lá acaba time nas
costas
5 eu não sei se funciona ainda mas
primeiro passo era batata já em
contraste a hori e levou ali já temos
aqui batata
agora é só colocar a bagagem agora já
tem um gancho
se o paciente experimenta a única coisa
que sei fazer gasolina batata as brigas
aqui e ativos voltam a campo mas o
contexto é só vocês não viram um vídeo
do canhão batatas vai perceber que
também vocês podem ver lá e agora só tem
uma uma soma é apertar aqui é que está
aqui já há previsões para 2011 e batata
sul desapareceu junto é envolta piccolo
a batata desapareceu
daqui e não é que deu muito errado mas
também sem batata bastante diz um jovem
com essa coisa ficasse em casa vem pra
que prometer um canhão botas só ter
visto prometeram não sabe o jogo me lê
ter um casa comer e o cabrito fugiu não
se gostou ou não tudo que é demais é uma
boa pessoa
o terceiro menor sugestões pessoas a
encontrar disse que embora e vamos lá
ver se funciona é cara lindo vamos
colocar aqui uma proteção e isso é que
outra proposta acaba com isso se já não
vai mal a ninguém e ele foi lá puxa na
rua bariri isso qualquer resultado
se já não dói olha aí você não é nada
muito fofa assim acabaria ela e ela vai
aumentar muito disposto a brincar ela
está mais preocupada em comer agora
porque é hora do almoço então eu acho
que eu não quero brincar lei podendo
brincar olhe ele brincava olhe olhe quer
brincar e brincar liceo isso é brincar
vai embora adore
eu não quero não falei com ele em
melbourne
adoro estas plantas isso é como
bissexual e agora eu só quero comer não
quer brincar eles têm que ser mais tarde
mas pessoal eu acho que até funcionou
porque deu uma duas marradas e não doeu
tanto então eu acho que o sino e
comentei em baixa o que vocês acham se
acham que funcionou se acham que não
funcionou e se acham que o blog gosto
porque se não gostar eu vou colocar isso
aqui pra sempre meus mas eu acho que eu
não estou a bola eu vou tirar vou tirar
o trono que eu gostaria sim mas não da
marinha ontem eu pensei que a comida
estava comendo muito poder na nova arena
calor em décadas entre o vídeo ainda
olha não podem faltar muito bom mas as
pessoas para que vocês gostem que
destruídos não foi inscrito no canal e
queremos sempre estar no vídeo deixei
muito claro que também porque esse jogo
é muito que o canal e um blog também
gosta em the boy discos off quem vai até
a próxima